a new book gives a rare close-up look at
fraternity life in America including the
highly scrutinized culture around
pledging between 2005 and 2007 teen at
least 72 boys died in fraternity related
incidents now that's according to the
book fraternity an inside look at a year
of college boys becoming men the author
is Alexandra Robbins she explores the
negative and the positive qualities of
fraternities so she interviewed hundreds
of fraternity brothers and alumni and
follow the journeys of two young men for
an entire year Alexandra Robbins joins
us at the table were glad to have you
here having me I think it's a good
description to call it rare because you
really are it's sort of like a fly on
the wall Jake and Oliver their names I'm
assuming those are not their correct
names but you really take those aren't
their correct names right that's not the
real location but you take us in real
time their thought process as they're
trying to decide how to pledge what to
pledge what happened between the two of
them the difference is and how it turned
out for them both well I don't want to
spoil the plot because it's purposely a
fun to read book so people keep reading
but I chose them both because they were
smart earnest nice fraternity members
which is not the kind of people that we
usually see in the media or pop culture
I wanted characters whom parents would
see their sons in and whom students
would see themselves and so they could
better relate to what it's like to be a
college guy today did they emerge from
the process I mean because you say it's
you know people their kids and do good
well-behaved kids and then they go to
into a fraternity and something happens
not to all of them but but it does
happen to some that that changes their
value structures what's what did you
have to both stories took took turns
that I wasn't surprising one turned that
what that that were surprising one was
very positive and when turned I was sort
of a little bit of a Breaking Bad arc
mildly I guess we've covered a number of
very painful hazing deaths on this show
and particularly the Piazza family who
lost their son you mentioned them in
your book yes yeah how prevalent is that
hazing that goes on in fraternities not
all fraternities hazed but the ones that
do it's more than just it's really more
like trying to get pledges to bond so
that they emerge supposedly with
lifelong friends and the feeling that
they've earned the letters to stop
hazing fraternities can stop
what they have to do is replace the
pledge period with another more
challenging bonding activity like for
example a tough extended community
service project that's not run by
fraternity brothers so there's no
hierarchy you said that Animal House
really changed the cultures how as to
how we look at fraternities and hazing
then on some level they made it cool
fraternities were actually dwindling in
popularity until Animal House came out
then the movie made students think that
they were supposed to drink and party in
college then soon afterward the drinking
age was raised and even more students
flocked to fraternity houses whether or
not they were drinking or not they were
Greek since then and I think it's
perpetuated by social media many
students come to college expecting to
party and they often do it at fraternity
houses because it's the only place you
can get a drink even though a lot of
eternity houses are under sanction
aren't supposed to do it and all that
nevertheless it somehow happens they can
drink unseen by law enforcement and
administrators but what's your big
takeaway because back to Nora's point I
keep thinking about the Piazza family
too because we've talked to them you
know this hazing is so devastating and
so upsetting to families who are going
through it you say that it's down but
yet it is still happening it is still
have what should parents know it's
they've got a teenage child who's
heading off to college at a young
vulnerable time in their life yes
parents who are watching this who have
high school or college age kids want to
know how to keep their kids safe and
students and advisors gave me a ton of
great suggestions for this so I'll give
you three right now one when you're a
high schooler visit campus on a party
night to see if you're comfortable with
the vibe whether or not you want to go
Greek too if you're interested in
joining a Greek chapter ask cultural
coed or LGBTQ chapters about it they can
tell you whether that chapter treats
people with respect and three parents
and students should communicate openly
during high school and college about
drinking sex and Greek life discussions
that this book is meant to help
facilitate because your book was
disturbing but it was also reassuring
because you said we hear about it in the
news but hazing is down and there are a
lot of good fraternities in the country
there are high risk return ''tis and
there are low risk of eternities it's
just we don't hear much about the low
risk eternities but I promise you
they're out there now ease into Robins
thank you so much
you